It gets all the nations together...
..and they make decisions, hopefully good decisions.
One of the first peacekeeping missions were in my country.
So for me, the UN is not a distant kind of organization.
I think it is now perceived as null and void...
...because in essence, I think the US is making all the vital decisions.
On a rudimentary basis, yes...
But maybe their strategy would be to refocus what their goals and objectives are.
Absolutely, at this point I think the world is globalizing more and more...
...and we need to kind of pull together to govern the world more as one unified whole.
How the UN is structured right now, it's ineffective...
...but I think that it's important that countries continue to create and enhance dialogues...
...so that there is effective interplay.
The world needs the UN more than ever.
And it's a question of how you define who is part of the UN.
It's good for humanitarian aid...
...and going in there but even their peacekeeping troops don't do anything.
They can't keep the peace.
Not effective.
Ultimately, it has not been as effective as it's initially set up to be.
You know it's really, in my view, seen as more as an impotent body.
It is effective but it needs to take more, it needs to be more noticed.